oh
[Applause]
you'd have to talk to the people who are
working here hey
uh uh
i think we're probably yeah no it was
fun they actually just got up i think
they they they they just got up and
decided they'd had enough i didn't even
jacob's out of the room right now
because i told him i'm gonna go like
this [ __ ] on fire
[Music]
[Applause]
i want to tell you guys something i want
to tell you guys something so here's my
theory on people like that
and so i was waiting for her to say one
more thing what i like to do is this
i like to wait until everybody in the
audience is so angry at them
and let me tell you why because when i
because when it's somebody like that i
want to be able to say anything and the
only way i can say anything is getting
everybody else to a point of like get
them the [ __ ] out of here
[Applause]
so
and you can ask kenny and jacob has seen
it a ton of times
people like this
i don't want them to leave on their own
i want to walk them
i was just waiting for her to say one
more thing
oh i can't believe it
can't believe olivia newton john got out
of here
without me being able to say anything
damn it
now did the dude say anything
yeah i think we got a glimpse into his
little life there
that was the white will and jada right
there
[Applause]
[Music]
well i hope she went back to the 1980s
with her haircut and
[Applause]
she did she was straight out of flock of
seagulls i was like what the [ __ ] is
that
oh guys i was waiting she just left i
couldn't believe it so you guys get to
hear it since she can't
i wish she came back
what's that
no she did not go to the bathroom
she did not go to the bathroom
hey by the way i'm not gonna lie to you
i have to be completely honest i was so
curious what her question was
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
but you know how the story goes another
day another dollar howler 7 p.m once
again i'm breaking up the birds